Okay Michael have you thought about it? Do you know what the answer is?
>> Yeah. I think, you know, you asked it in a
funny way, but I think, what you're asking maybe was pretty
simple. So let, let me, let me see if I can
talk it through. So ,we've got n data points, each learner is
a zeroth order polynomial. So you, you said the ensemble rule
is that you learn over a subset, a zeroth order polynomial
is just (no period) Well, we said that the thing that
minimizes the average. Sorry, that minimizes the expected error, or the squared
error [INAUDIBLE] it's just the average. So, if
the sets are indistinct sets, with one data point
each, then each, of the individual learners, is
just going to learn the average. Then they get, not
the average sorry. The actual output value of
each individual point is the average, and then the
combining algorithm, to combine all the pieces of
the ensemble into one answer, combines with the mean.
So ,it's going to combine the mean of those
each of which is the data point, so it's
the mean of the data points. So, the ensemble
outputs, I don't know, I'd say average or mean?
>> Yes.
>> Or zeroth order polynomial of the data set,
or, you know, one node decision tree, or ,uh.
>> A constant? Which happens to be the
mean of the data. Haven't we seen this before?
>> It seems to come up a lot,
when we are outputting very simple hypotheses.
>> Right. And the last time we did this, if I recall correctly, this is what
happens ,if you do an unweighted average with kNN where k is equal to n.
>> Oh, right. Like, like, right. An N-NN.
>> N-NN.
>> Mm.
>> Mm, so we should probably do
something a little smarter than this then. And,
I thought that we might look at some of the housing data, because, no
one's started looking at the housing data
yet. [LAUGH] Okay, so let's look at that
right quick and see if we can figure out how this works. And then
see if we can do something a little bit better, even better than that. Okay?